bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ça vous regarde version déconfit les
c'est parti voici le sommaire long de
choc après la mort de georges floyd aux
etats unis cette fois page en france
manifestation impressionnante hier soir
à paris contre les violences policières
à l'appel de la famille d'adama traoré
ce jeune homme décédé en garde à vue il
ya quatre ans floyd traoré le parallèle
est il vraiment pertinent existe-t-il
une forme de racisme dans les rangs de
la police française et au delà
n'est-il pas temps d'avoir un débat
apaisé sur les violences policières dans
notre pays sujets brûlants dont on parle
calmement dont 20,9
ils ont le vent en poupe mais maintenant
il va falloir conclure on va parler de
la stratégie des verts aux municipales
pas toujours lisibles allié à gauche par
endroits ils font cavalier seul pour
d'autres et puis qu'on fasse un faux
anti écolo qui va de la droite aux
marcheurs alors la vague verte pourrait
finalement n'être qu'une petite
vaguelette
on en parlera enfin notre grand témoin
ce soit a eu plusieurs vies journaliste
député maire candidat à la
présidentielle il nous revient avec un
livre manifeste sur l'écologie noël
mamère est avec nous ce soir n'a donc
pour le programme hashtag sévère ça ça
n'a pas changé on lire
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
une foule
une foule immense une foule jeune très
jeune black blanc beur qui descendent
dans la rue en masse une semaine après
la mort de georges floyd cet
afro-américain quadragénaire asphyxié
par un policier blanc à minneapolis
ce donc vous le voyez les images de la
première manifestation en france une
marche immense je le disais une forme de
marée humaine devant le tribunal de
grande instance de paris dans le
nord-est de la capitale manifestation
contre les violences policières à
l'appel du comité adama traoré
ce jeune homme noir mort en 2016 après
son interprétation de la manifestation a
été interdite et pourtant malgré cela
elle a rassemblé vingt mille personnes
bonsoir noël mamère au sort et merci
d'être avec nous vous connaissez bien le
sujet des violences policières vous avez
présidé en 2014
ici même à l'assemblée nationale une
commission d' enquête sur le maintien de
l'ordre dont les manifestations
s'étaient après la mort de rémy fraysse
rémy fraysse ce jeune homme qui avait
trouvé la mort face à un policier
c'était sur le site du barrage de 2,6 20
on s'en souvient dans le tarn vous
débattez ce soir avec didier paris ce
bon soir débutait la république en
marche côte-d'or et magistrat de
profession et puis derrière son écran en
duplex nous attend yves lefebvre bonsoir
merci avec nous est policier secrétaire
général sgp police fo je vous donne la
parole mais ce que dans un tout petit
instant mais vous le savez ça vous
regarde ça commence toujours par un
regard celui de stéphane stéphane
blakowski est ce que cette comparaison
traoré floyd et pertinente pas vraiment
me semble-t-il
si j'ai bien compris c'est tout de suite
bonsoir stéphane bon sens myriam
toujours bien compris ce soir ben si
j'ai bien compris
myriam la société française au gie sous
l'hégémonie culturelle des états unis on
regarde des films tournés à hollywood
des séries diffusées sur netflix notre
musique préférée c'est le raf le rnb
tous les restos du coup on en mange des
hamburgers et figurez-vous même que le
site touristique le plus visité en
france c'est le disneyland paris va
c'est à peu près la même chose pour les
mouvements citoyens
le mouvement me to hell et sur twitter
en 2017 après l'affairé ben spies et le
mouvement black live matters est né en
2013 sur twitter aussi après
l'assassinât d'un jeune afro-américain
en floride alors forcément dans ce
contexte c'est même pas tellement
étonnant qu'on ne confonde complètement
ce qui se passe en france et aux états
unis mais en même temps on peut quand
même se poser la question est ce que
c'est vraiment la même chose en tout cas
pour assa traoré la frères pardon la
third adama traoré qui a été tué par des
gendarmes en 2016 ça lui fait aucun
doute
selon elle la situation en france est
exactement la même qu'aux états unis au
niveau des violences policières
sinon pire en l'écoutant l'indignation
que l'on dénonce aux états unis il se
passe exactement la même chose en france
en france c'est encore pire aux etats
unis les policiers ont été limogés en
france les gendarmes ont été récompensés
il faut savoir que quand mon frère va
mourir nous avons monsieur leroux et
cazeneuve qui vont faire le déplacement
chez nous à beaumont pour remercier les
gendarmes alors cela dit si l'on peut
comprendre bien sûr la colère dassa
traoré même si on peut s'étonner que la
justice n'ait pas estimé nécessaire de
renvoyer les gendarmes qui ont tué son
frère devant la justice bien malgré tout
ce serait très exagéré très très exagéré
de considérer que de violences
policières en france c'est la même chose
qu'aux états unis pour vous citer
quelques chiffres on estime que chaque
année aux états unis
un millier de personnes sont tuées par
des policiers donc si c'était la même
chose en france de même proportion ça
voudrait dire que les policiers tuent
chaque année 200 personnes en france qui
n'est absolument pas le cas
la proportion enfin le chiffre est
plutôt donne à dix fois moins une
vingtaine de personnes
si on doit faire une moyenne j'ai aussi
été un autre exemple lors des émeutes à
los angeles en 1992 il ya eu 50
cinq morts lors des émeutes dans les
banlieues en 2005 ya eu quatre morts et
aucune de ces personnes n'a été tué par
un policier alors bien sûr il s'agit pas
du tout de nier les accusations de
racisme qui sont portées régulièrement
contre la police française je vous
rappelle que jacques toubon qu'est le
défenseur des droits a commandé une
enquête en 2016 selon laquelle la
probabilité d'être contrôlé par la
police et 20 fois plus importante quand
on est un jeune homme qui est perçu par
les policiers comme noirs ou arabes
donc c'est un chiffre qui témoigne
effectivement des tensions de plus en
plus importante dans le coeur dans les
cités entre les jeunes et les policiers
c'est un phénomène inquiétant mais au
lieu de prétendre que le phénomène de la
violence policière est exactement le
même qu'aux états unis
je me demande si au contraire on devrait
pas considérer que le modèle américain
et le repoussoir absolu ce contrat ne
devrait pas tenter d'agir pour que d'ici
quelques années la situation en france
ne détiennent pas réellement comme elle
l'est aujourd'hui aux états unis
merci beaucoup stéphane noël mamère la
démonstration de stéphane est implacable
si on regarde les chiffres mais cette
comparaison la vue dans le cortège hier
ses deux visages là qui sont déjà deux
symboles georges floyd aux états unis
adama traoré en france cette comparaison
là elle vous choque ou vous la comprenez
je la comprends de la part de ces jeunes
qui sont absolument choquée par le
caractère discriminatoire de la police
dans ce pays
en même temps on ne peut pas évidemment
mettre sur le même plan ce qui se passe
aux etats unis les violences policières
des états unis et celle de la france
mais enfin on est dans une séquence qui
dure déjà depuis longtemps qui a
d'ailleurs commencé par un changement de
la doctrine de maintien de l'ordre avec
le rapport contre lequel j'ai voté de la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
c'est nous-mêmes qui avions saisi avec
pouria amirshahi le président de
l'assemblée nationale qui a permis à
hull cette enquête et ce rapport du
défenseur des droits qui a demandé entre
autres l'interdiction de de la ldd mais
la réalité c'est qu'il y a dans la
police française aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas le nier le défenseur des droits
viennent d'ailleurs de le dire dans une
décision qui date du 13 mai une sorte de
racisme systémique dont qui ne doit pas
qui doit être détachés les
individus des policiers individus mais
qui doit être au contraire rattaché à
une culture qui existent et qui a des
précédents historiques c'est une
histoire de la police avait que
l'algérie française la poursuite des des
travailleurs north africa est
aujourd'hui 17e situation socio
économique qui fait que la plupart de
ceux qui aujourd'hui son sens sans
emploi sont des enfants de l'immigration
postcoloniale beaucoup de choses déjà
dans ce que vous avez dit racisme
systémique on va y venir mais je
voudrais et je vous donne la parole
juste après m'adresser aux policiers que
vous êtes
yves lefebvre vous policiers américains
si vous aviez été américains aux états
unis auriez-vous mis un genou à terre
comme d'autres policiers ont pu le faire
en soutien évidemment avec avec georges
floyd et à sa famille je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas si j'aurais mis un genou à
terre ce que je suis certain c'est
j'aurais agi de la même façon je
soutiens le dessus que j'ai agi la façon
j'ai agi depuis qu'on nous annoncer ça
c'est à dire considérer que le la mort
de georges floyd et est constitutive un
assassinat d'un individu qui n'avait
plus rien à faire qu'il ne peut rien
faire qui n'aurait jamais dû faire
partie des forces de l'anp qui s'est
passé aux états unis est inacceptable
intolérable c'est un assassinat pur et
simple mais ne comparons pas ce que fait
la police nationale avec la police
américaine
deux affaires fly traoré n'ont
absolument rien à voir l'une avec
l'autre donc n'ont absolument rien à
voir si au demeurant je comprends
aisément et c'est selon ce qu'a déclaré
monsieur mamère c'est peut-être un des
seul point sur lequel je serais d'accord
avec lui
je considère effectivement que la
famille est légitime aujourd'hui bien
évidemment et illégitime depuis
longtemps a demandé un procès a demandé
un procès d'avoir des conclusions de la
justice c'est pas acceptable que séduire
depuis quatre ans c'est pas normal ils
demandent un procès ou à l'existence est
niée pour l'instant c'est parole contre
parole
est il contre expertise oui enfin ceci
étant il ya qu un format d expertise
reconnue et moi je parle ici on nous
promet que me le confirmer en tant que
magistrat ou ancien magistrat celle
expertises judiciaires en la matière
mais le problème c'est que aujourd'hui
en france aujourd'hui en france on aime
technique pour menotter les gens on doit
menotté les gens dans le dos et nous par
le fait quand on a affaire à quelqu'un
ce débat qu'il veut pas je dirais sont
acceptés d'être menotté
le placage je dirais ventrale est la
seule technique aujourd'hui utilisés
alors comme polluées le bdr sa part
usuelle bédié tout à l'heure moi je n'ai
pas d'à printemps c'est le lb dg pas non
plus d'importance et aucun policier n'a
d'importance et le paillage centrale
trouvons une technique et nous serons
ouverts et sans doute et nous n'aurions
pas débat de ce genre de phénomène alors
le claquage centrales pour expliquer ce
serait fait c'est exactement ce qu'elle
subit adama traoré lors de chirurgies
l'interpellation en garde à vue la
question est de savoir si c'est ce
plaquage centrale qui est directement à
l'origine de son décès didier paris les
deux affaires n'ont rien à voir et
pourtant dans ces cortèges
hier vous avez vingt mille personnes
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes qui
ont décidé de venir malgré
l'interdiction malgré la crise sanitaire
qui n'est pas coté totalement terminée
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est quand
on est député et qu'on a qu'on a ça ce
sentiment là de jeunes qui vous disent
on a peur on a peur quand on quand on
n'est pas blanc on a une sorte de
sentiment d'impunité de la police je
regarde des images l'équipe assure
finalement dû multicolores absolu cette
manifestation donc soyons un peu
vigilants pour revenir quand même vos
propos départ moi je suis comme tout le
monde
atterré de ce qu'on a pu voir à la
télévision s'agissant d'or floyd s'est
pas seulement une technique de maintien
d'une personne interpellée quelle qu'en
soit la raison au sol qui pose problème
c'est arrêter votre monde pendant sept
voire huit minutes sept voire huit
minutes aux policiers à parler
d'assassinât
je pense pas que ce soit un propos
excessifs et ce qui m'a interdit de
lana'i l'état il ya encore plus chaud un
jeu assez c'est l'espèce d'apathie
générale des autres fonctionnaires de
police autour
pourquoi parce que je reprends pas les
propos de noël mamère mais il ya aux
états unis sans aucun doute à fond de
culture raciste qui est profonde et
profondément ancré et qui se double
d'une extrême difficulté 2
de contenir la police dans certains cas
pourquoi parce que c'est un grand pays
mais c'est aussi un pays où il ya plus
de 700 services de police différent un
pays fédéral
aucune unité de police ne fait dans un
état du tout le même fonctionnement de
la libye ce matin là moi je me félicite
du fonctionnement centralisé notre
police nationale parce que ça permet
d'avoir des réponses unique est en fait
des des modes de fonctionnement mais
vous avez des jeunes et c'est pas
nouveau 1
ça fait longtemps qu'on entend par les
discriminations sentiment de peur de
mourir devant la police le pôle du logo
boulot face est cédée c'est peut-être du
sentiment enfin tout cas c'est ce qu'ils
disent qu'est-ce que vous qui ont eu les
hanter la majorité vous leur répondez
venons j je présente la majorité je suis
aussi un citoyen comme tout le monde
tellement je n'y mets pas l'idée que la
police serait raciste mais comme dans
tout groupe social il peut y avoir des
gens et qui n'ont rien à faire dans les
services de police qui n'ont pas des
comportement adéquat si on revient quand
même sur la sphère adama traoré face que
je note c'est que c'est une procédure
judiciaire en cours
voici en judiciaire en cours et la
réaction d'un certain nombre de gens
plus ou moins instrumentalisé dont acte
c'est comme ça mais la réaction des gens
vient de ce que va dernières expertises
judiciaires pâle expertise payé par la
famille c'est pas de même nature
la dernière expertise judiciaire conclu
à un décès qui n'aurait pas
nécessairement la cause que la famille
traoré attendent pour vous les partys
privés de la famille ne permet pas de
rouvrir le dossier du fer attendait
humainement je comprends qu'elle ait pu
le faire mais nous sommes dans un état
de droit ne mettons pas au même plan une
expertise rendue par des médecins
rémunérés par une famille et les
expertises judiciaires fans à ses fans
devaient intervenir
et puis vous
je vous donne la parole donnée ma mère
après ses fans j'étais frappé par
l'unanimité qui existent sur le plateau
entre à ce que 10 à noël mamère ce que
disait yves lefebvre est ce que disait
le député de la côte d'or
je me trompe pas dire et enfin didier
parrish excuses à monsieur pâris j'avais
oublié le prénom voulais pas me tromper
mais ce qui me surprend c'est que le il
ya une vraie unanimité on est tous
choqués pourtant il n'y a pas de prise
de position officielle à ma connaissance
du gouvernement français pour condamner
ces images affreuses d'assassinât de
georges pahud alors comment se fait-il
qu'ils aient pas de prise de position ce
ne sera pas une manière justement de
bien se démarquer des états unis les
états unis déry qui n'étaient pas
tendres l'égard de ce qui s'était passé
mais en même temps ça s'est passé aux
états immo je refuse tout tout mélange
je veux dire encore une fois la police
française vous avez cité des chiffres
qui sont sans commune mesure et vous
même vous vous venez de citer des
chiffres qui était intéressant il ya
juste aussi des chiffres que vous ne
citez pas assez il ya plus de 800 mille
interpellations par an en france pour
des faits graves je dirais atteintes aux
personnes trafic de drogue et ainsi de
suite
nous avons un nombre de cas extrêmement
faible de entre guillemets dérapage je
sais pas si c'est le bon terme et qu'on
n'oublie pas quand même que l'an dernier
c'est plus 30000 agression à l'égard de
fonctionnaires de police qui aurait
alors c'est bien mais il faut bien aussi
que la police rien martingale qui est la
phase d'adaptation à la situation alors
je vais vous passez la réponse du
gouvernement et puis vous réagirez parce
que le gouvernement par la voix de ses
bêtes ndiaye et par la boîte christophe
castaner n'utilise pas le terme de
violences policières refusent de
l'utiliser systématique qui menait de
violence d'état en revanche il dit qu'il
est intransigeant et que toutes les
fautes commises sont sanctionnés écouter
christophe castaner c'était tout à
l'heure au sénat il faut faire en sorte
que chaque faute et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot y compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction et je suis
sur ce sujet intransigeant ça suffit ou
pas pour leur position intransigeante
mais si on peux moi je peux citer des
chiffres monsieur castaner il ya eu 19
demandes de tous
sur d'enquêté et 68 qui ont été classées
sans suite la police depuis longtemps
qu'il y est une instance indépendante
que le contrôleur ne soit pas en même
temps le contrôler et qu'à la place de
l'igpn on constitue une autorité le
système judiciaire pour juger les
policiers ne fonctionne pas dans notre
pays fonctionne pas puisque c'est les
policiers qui seraient eux contrôlent
eux-mêmes donc ça pose un problème il
faut il faut une autorité indépendante
j'ai entendu aussi il ya pas longtemps
un grand joueur de tennis et où le jeune
wilfried tsonga qui nous a expliqué que
le contrôle au faciès il en avait été
aussi victime donc ça on ne peut pas le
nier donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y a
un problème de confiance entre le peuple
et sa police que cette police elle n'a
pas compris plus pourquoi elle a été
créée c'est à dire d'abord la protection
des citoyens qu'elle est aujourd'hui
dans une logique sécuritaire mais elle
applique en fait les directives du
gouvernement d'ailleurs cette logique
sécuritaire
on l'a vu s'appliquer dans le contrôle
des manifestations ou le technique de la
mise à distance est devenue celle de
l'affrontement à notre dame des landes
ils l'ont payé cher à civens ils ont
payé de mort
les manifs contre la loi travail alors
les manifs les gilet jaune long payer
très chèrement avec et théo qu'il faut
une réforme de la police des polices et
une réforme du maintien de l'ordre
il faut qu'il y ait un débat pour
rétablir la confiance entre le peuple
entre la population française et sa
police d'ailleurs ça rendrait beaucoup
plus de services à la police qui est
stigmatisé parce que regarder on
applaudit tous les soirs les les
soignants ce qui était tout à fait
normal et ce que l'on appelait les
premiers de corvée mais les policiers
faisait partie des premiers de corvée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans notre
pays on a appliqué la même politique
sécuritaire pour la gestion du coville
que pour les manifestations en est les
champions d'europe en termes de contrôle
20 millions de personnes ont été
contrôlées et un million d'âmes en
champion d'europe on aurait ça veut dire
que ce que ça veut dire que cet état ce
gouvernement est là une défiance
vis-à-vis de ses citoyens alors on va
partir parce que ce seul critère c'est
n'est qu'une affirmation de sa faiblesse
la défiance la défiance un tiers des
français ne font pas confiance à leur
police yves lefebvre sur ce
j'ai là est ce que vous seriez prêt à
ouvrir ce débat là la confiance des
citoyens en leurs forces de l'ordre et
qu'au fond on sort du face à face
pourquoi pas à l'assemblée nationale
qu'un véritable débat si possible apaisé
se tiennent sur ce qu'on appelle les
violences policières
je suis prêt à tous les débats à tous
les débats effectivement pour qu'on
trouve une solution et qu'on puisse
retrouver des relations normales mais à
une condition c'est qu'on inverse les
propos tenus par noël mamère c'est à
dire qu'on considère que ce sont les
policiers qui sont systématiquement
violent et didier paris sur l'a10 s'est
fait assez faire c'est faire abstraction
c'est faire offense c'est une injure ni
plus ni moins aux trente mille policiers
blessés tous les ans c'est une insulte
aussi aux policiers qui sont agressés en
dehors de leurs heures de travail qui
ont eu ce fut encore le cas ce week-end
pour un de mes collègues restés avec son
gamin l'artiste grenelle qui a été
identifié comme policier alors oui il
faut débattre c'est la mousse de rêver
oui mais non mais la défiance monsieur
mamère la défiance vous permettrez de
considérer qu'elle dans l'autre sens sa
défiance
moi je peux tout entendre je pose
effectivement entendre un brillant
joueur de tennis dire qu'il a fait
l'objet de contrôles pas si large est un
leurre yves la vue sur cette dimension
là parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
la question des violences policières on
l'a vu pendant les manifestations
il ya eu aussi et vous il faut le dire
des policiers qui ont été touchés
directement par ces violences
mais sur le racisme parce que c'est ça
au fond l'actualité c'est de ça dont les
jeunes pas quand ils vont manifester sur
cette question du contrôle au faciès ce
sentiment d'un deux poids deux mesure
d'être discriminés qu'est ce que vous
répondez
et qu'est ce que vous répondez au
défenseur des droits qui vient de
publier une décision dans le 12e
arrondissement où les tigres puisque on
les appelle comme ça considéré ces
jeunes comme des indésirables avec des
contrôles d'identité perpétuel il
lefebvre didier parez juste après oui si
on considère si on prend une analyse de
ce qui se passe dans les quartiers dans
les zones de non droit parce que
malheureusement ce sont des zones de
non-droit tempe alors les gens qui
habitent ou pour les policiers qui
tentent d'y faire régner le one la
république
mais la faute appartient à qui la faute
appartient aux politiques rapport aux
politiques actuelles parc à celui là
mais aux politiques de
ti générationnel pourquoi parce qu'on a
fait en sorte de ne rien faire dans ces
quartiers j'ai encore en mémoire à miser
intérieur qui prétendait vouloir
nettoyer au kärcher mais c'est une pure
et simple provocation nous seuls qui a
voulu faire quelque chose pour ces
quartiers c'est jean pierre chevènement
c'est le seul cas voulu le faire et on a
tout balayé d'un revers de main gérard
collomb quand il est arrivé il nous a
parlé de la police de sécurité du
quotidien et des quartiers de reconquête
républicaine
on n'a pas avancé on n'a pas avancé d'un
du nom sera la matière donc moi je suis
prêt à tous les débats mais à partir du
moment qu'on arrive avec un climat
apaisé
donc il concerne un moment donné de
considérer si je peux me permettre
simplement de considérer mois policiers
je considère aujourd'hui le racisme dans
les rangs de la police ne doit pas
exister ne doit pas exister mais le
racisme anti policiers ne doit pas
exister non plus et elle malheureusement
est la situation aujourd'hui est ce que
vous craignez un embrasement dans ce
qu'on appelle les banlieues aujourd'hui
il ya l'étincelle georges floyd adama
tard oui mais il ya aussi la crise la
crise économique et sociale qui se
profile oui oui bien évidemment avec des
restrictions de déplacement
vous avez des jeunes aux dents les
parents sont issus de pays étrangers qui
n'aspire qu'à une chose c'est retourner
dans leur pays d'origine ou rencontrer
leur famille d'origine
l'été qui ne pourront pas le faire tant
bien évidemment on va en aura je crains
jeu
j'espère avoir tort mais je crains
malheureusement un grosse embrassement
un immense embrasement des banlieues
avec ce qui s'est passé hier soit comme
étant le je dirais le commencement de
cette période qui va t'il qu'il a
manifestée rires je rectifie qu'ils
disaient bordeaux n'ont même pas s'ils
font ça si vous me permettez tu vas vers
simplement c'est pour ça qu'il faut
aujourd'hui se poser et avant un débat
apaisé sensible baptisé systématiquement
comme c'est le cas pour une frange à
petit les forces de l'ordre sinon nous
n'arriverons jamais à sorties vous allez
avoir le mot de la fin didier paris
c'est ce que vous êtes prêt à appeler
sur ce plateau un débat un débat qui
peut se tenir au sein de la
représentation nationale ou au fond
toutes les parties serait entendu parce
qu'il ya besoin de paroles bien besoin
de vider son sac qui qui peut te promets
moi
qui peut être contre un débat évidemment
pas à condition qu'ils soient
débaptisées à condition qu'ils soient
sur des bases saines et sereine et
qu'ils puissent déboucher
je reconnais volontiers qu'on a une
crise de confiance dans la
dans la relation avec la police mais
quand j'entends noël mamère qui dit la
police la police ne protège plus nos
concitoyens je comprends qu'une crise de
confiance dire ça c'est à mes yeux un
truc enfin c'est insupportable il
faisant la différence entre les
événements de rue les manifestations de
rue qui sont excessivement difficile à
contenir
et on a vu effectivement une adaptation
de la technique policière parce qu'à un
moment il y avait des débordements avec
le travail normal de la police trial et
jacqueline policière mais sur l'aspect
discrimination le contrôle au faciès on
en parle depuis les la haine de mathieu
kassovitz et 1995 à avensan n'existe pas
et ramène à la moelle qu'on fait
attendez juste regardé j'ai tout on
prend un très bon exemple le
commissariat du 12ème
oui il investiguer là dessus qu'est ce
qui se passe il se passe qu'on a eu un
foyer sans doute très très très mauvais
comptes doute qu'on ne doit pas laisser
les policiers concernés dans le deuxième
ils ont été condamnés ils ont été
condamnés c'est l'honneur de la justice
c'est l'honneur de la police pour
combien il ne dit attendez réformer
l'apa les structures de de contrôle des
services de police et de gendarmerie et
qui sont je peux vous dire extrêmement
dur à l'égard des policiers des
gendarmes quand il faut additionner
chargée d'une enquête sous l'autorité de
la justice
on est dans un état de droit je dis pas
que tout est fait bien évidemment il
faut penser des deux côtés en vie mesure
ça vient trop duré des années et des
années oui mais sans parler des
inondations il ya eu beaucoup de
beaucoup de enfin ça mérite qu'on en
discute ya aucun doute ça mérite qu'on
remette sans doute à plat un certain
nombre de choses pourquoi pas même un
certain nombre de techniques
d'interpellation pourquoi pas même si je
vous rend sensible au fait que les
techniques d'interpellation qui sont
actuellement utilisées leçon pour
protéger au maximum la personne et
policiers et l'environnement si on n'a
pas ça si on n'a pas ça on pourra voir
des techniques plus violente plus
difficile à mettre en oeuvre mais après
ça mérite dix salles ils ont mis en
difficulté café dit
la vente parce que c'est terminé le
débat risque d'être difficile quand on
voit des députés comme eric ciotti une
trentaine d'autres députés qui demandent
que les policiers soient pas identifiés
absolue avec tout le monde et nous aussi
il faut et si nous ne débattons qu'avec
les gens avec lesquels nous sommes d'un
an mais aussi rapide de m l'assemblée
soucier aussi les citoyens sur ce que le
problème de la protection dont je
parlais tout à l'heure je dis pas que
les policiers choqués soit vous dites
c'est le sentiment que les français
qu'on a bien insisté sur les moyens ce
sentiment puis il ya les faits on a
essayé de donner les chiffres et de
restituer ce sentiment qui monte dans le
pays merci beaucoup merci messieurs
merci le fait vous restez avec nous noël
mamère merci stéphane également on va
parler à présent de votre livre dans un
instant d'écologie pour sauver nos vies
mais je voulais également vous
interroger sur ce scrutin qui arrivent
les municipales et vous parlez de votre
famille politique europe ecologie les
verts vous avez le vent en poupe
faut dire qu'effectivement l'écologie
est devenue la priorité des priorités
les résultats du premier tour des
municipales ont été bons et pourtant
pourtant noël mamère rien ne garantit
que vous allez gagner de nouvelles
villes pourquoi on voit cela avec mario
becker et on discute juste après ils
sont arrivés en tête du premier tour à
lyon grenoble et strasbourg
ils ont réalisé de beaux scores à nantes
lille ou toulouse
une belle dynamique pour les écologistes
qui sont cinq fois plus présent au
second tour qu'en 2014
mais pourront-ils transformer l'essai à
l'entre-deux tours cette fois ils ont
décidé de ne plus à lier
systématiquement avec le parti
socialiste
une forme de volonté de la part des
écologistes tels jamais su à quoi soit h
et d'affirmer leur orientation politique
d'affirmer leurs thématiques de campagne
et peut être également de venger contre
guillemets ce qu'ils ont considéré comme
étant un affront de la part du parti
socialiste depuis de nombreuses années
les écologistes entendent peser
et devenir incontournable à lille et
strasbourg ils ont décidé d'affronter
leurs traditionnels alliés socialistes
pour la première fois martine aubry
devra batailler avec un écologiste mais
à rennes et nantes
ils se sont rangés derrière la liste de
gauche des alliances parfois contraintes
comme à rouen où l'incendié de l'usiné
lubrizol laissait pourtant espérer une
victoire aux écologistes
le 28 juin europe ecologie les verts
devraient conserver grenoble mais la
conquête d'une nouvelle grande ville
semble compliqué arrivé en tête à lyon
ils vont devoir affronter la liste
commune entre la république en marche et
les républicains
l'enjeu de ces municipales pour les
écologistes c'est aussi de préparer les
futures échéances électorales et
apparaître comme un parti de
gouvernement
bonsoir géraldine woessner bonsoir vous
avez lu pour nous l'écologie pour sauver
nos vies et parcouru ce que je n'ai eu
que ce mas ardent chauffer être honnête
quand même les petits matins on en parle
dans un instant vous avez retenu
quelques chapitres cette journaliste au
point et chroniqueuse dans cette
émission mais pour rebondir sur le sujet
de marion becker vous avez le vent en
poupe c'est très clair on sent bien
qu'ils aient demande écologique aux fous
vous vous récolter les fruits de cette
demande c'est quand même les verts
europe ecologie les verts qui progresse
ça reste toujours un chemin de croix
quand même un entre les deux tours on
sent que voilà vous avez encore un petit
parti alors je dirais pour parler comme
un pédant que le paradigme politique du
xxième siècle c'est clair c'est
l'écologie elle est maintenant en tête
de toutes les enquêtes d'opinion bien
avant les questions de sécurité mais
toujours lié à la question sociale
et ça je pense qu'il faut que l'on
comprenne bien que l'écologie ne peut
être limitée aux questions strictement
les premiers rôles dans un scrutin comme
les municipales vous êtes arrivé en tête
dans beaucoup de villes et c'était quand
même une grosse surprise on sentait
qu'il est dur à tenir parce que pour le
situations sont difficiles et
compliquées bien sûr que c'est difficile
ils vont risquer de perdre beaucoup
les grandes formations politiques
traditionnelles résiste encore même si
aujourd'hui elles sont beaucoup plus
affaiblie mais faut qu'elle comprenne
une chose d'abord la gauche parce que je
pense que l'écologie est une nouvelle
composante de la gauche qui a placé la
question écologique et sociale au centre
de son projet de transformation de la
société
mais il faut que nos partenaires
comprennent que la transformation de la
reconstruction écologique elle ne se
fera qu'au tour des questions que posent
les écologistes et donc
l'écologie doit devenir central
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un petit peu
plus compliqué entre le premier et le
deuxième tour de wild card et regarder
les villes que vous visiez besançon
peut-être on va gagner je vous l errance
lyon on peut grenoble vous allez garder
probablement eric tu es là eric piolle
loïc médailles gagnées
regardez vous étiez un des premiers
maires un écolo dans le pays dans les
grandes villes oublions vous avez vu ce
qui se passe à lyon on va gagner à lyon
vous allez gagner malgré un front anti
écolo parce que gérard collomb leur
écoute quelqu'un ça peut être redoutable
parce que c'est quand même dingue c'est
qu'on ait un front anti écolo moi je
préfère qu'on ait un front anti extrême
droite on a l'impression que les
écologistes seraient une menace pour
l'avenir de l'humanité
sauf qu'aujourd'hui les utopistes ce
sont ceux qui veulent maintenir le statu
quo le statu quo politique qu'on a
connue durant ce dernier siècle et le
statu quo dans le système économique et
social
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les réalistes
sont les écologies d'ailleurs partout où
ils sont allés où sont présents à tous
les étages de la démocratie que ce soit
dans les communes où dans les régions où
nous avons beaucoup de vice présidence
on a même eu une vie ce prix une
présidente de région du nord pas de
calais qui s'appelait marie christine
blandin ya déjà plus de 30 ans
maintenant partout où ils sont ils
montrent qu'ils sont responsables
regardez ce qu'ils ont contribué à faire
à paris regardez ce qu'ils ont mais il
faut quand même penser encore des
alliances et c'est le cas à paris c'est
l'âge où d'autres mots les identitaires
les écologistes ont des quads amant
doivent passer des coalitions
mais ils ne doivent plus passer des
coalitions soumis au grand frère qui
était jusqu'à maintenant le parti ce
service mais en mettant au coeur de leur
alliance la question écologique et ceux
ci s'interroge l'allier socialiste c'est
l'allié évident pour les verts le sk
livre ça n'a pas marché on sent que
c'est pas si évident n'a pas d'alliés
évident les alliés évident d'abord il
faut que les écologistes sache qui sans
leur adversaire et qui choisissent leurs
partenaires et leurs partenaires ne
peuvent être que des partenaires de la
gauche parce que la gauche et la
tolérance le partage la défense de
l'égalité des droits qui ne sont pas des
valeurs défendues par la droite jusqu'à
maintenant mais il n'est pas question de
faire alliance avec une gouille martin
vous avez toujours fait alliance allait
la demander à martine aubry pour tl qui
a claqué la cua elle ne veut pas
discuter de manière un peu plus profonde
avec les écologistes
vous dites que ne l'ont pas nous marier
au salon va faire parts partenariat avec
une gauche productiviste avec une gauche
souverainiste avec une gauche anti
européenne
oui nous sommes prêts à des alliances
avec une gauche écologie c est avec une
société civile mobilisez vous les avez
vus avec allah soit chez adama traoré où
qu'ils soient dans les manifestations
pour le climat ils ont horreur des
partis politiques mais ils sont en
attente de quelque chose et c'est à nous
de le porter c'est notre responsabilité
historique
l'union de la gauche en tenue le 22 avec
les ados ça veut dire l'union de la
gauche
je pense qu'il est je pense qu'il peut y
avoir un grand rassemblement autour de
l'écologie ce qui est pas exactement la
même chose parce que il n'y aura pas que
des représentants des partis de gauche
et la roue ici des militants et des
citoyens qui se mobilisent tous les
jours elle injustement pour se
rassembler il faut des idées écologiques
vous avez lu le livre je me servais je
me suis focalisé quand même sur quelques
chapitres moi je vous avoue que j'ai été
très surprise parce que ce qui me frappe
en lisant votre livre est en vous
écoutant aussi c'est cet énorme
contradiction qui a entre l'afld
l'objectif que vous affirmez dans votre
livre pour une écologie par le bas qui
implique les pauvres en lutte pour de
meilleures conditions de vie et les
combats que vous défendez qui
aboutissent souvent exactement à
l'inversé je prends vraiment comme
emblématique votre position sur les ogm
qui vous caractérisent kiki qui a fait
votre notoriété vous y consacrer des
pages en restant complètement bloquée
sur un ancien logiciel sur les premières
peur qui ont conduit les ong à s'élever
contre et vous aussi dans les années 90
parce que les grandes firmes qui les
commercialisaient symbolise l oppression
sur sur le monde paysan
mais aujourd'hui on est en 2020 les
connaissances ont considérablement
progressé
la non dangerosité des ogm pour les
hommes pour l'environnement fait
consensus au sein de la communauté
scientifique le lot ms toutes les
agences
majeur scientifique majeure dans le
monde le considère comme sur un 30 ans
d'études pas pas un mort pas une
intoxication
alors on peut y rester opposés pour des
raisons religieuses philosophiques même
pour un pour des raisons de modèle
économique
mais prétendre que c'est pour défendre
l'environnement ça devient difficile et
ce silence silence alors que le giec lui
même le giec écrit que les ogm font
partie des solutions demain ça pose
question et moi je voulais vous
interroger sur des cas concrets que je
n'ai pas vu dans votre livre en asie un
riz ogm enrichi à la vitamine a le riz
doré pourrait sauver des dizaines de
millions d'enfants de la malnutrition il
ya cinq cent mille dit qu'ils deviennent
aveugles
chaque année à cause des carences en
bêta carotène ce riz cet ogm il est
développé par un consortium qui comprend
le talent est à du bangladesh
les semences ne sont pas stériles elles
sont donnés gratuitement et sabha ça
n'existe pas vous ne le citepa une
papaye ogm résistants un virus a sauvé
littéralement les petits producteurs
d'ail
pas un mot et quand vous des ogm de la
réponse élevé le tendre et qui sont
résistants à certains insectes ravageurs
permettent une réduction de 40% des
usages de pesticides qui est vertueux
pour l'environnement ça vous ne vous
n'en parlez pas non plus et quand vous
dénoncer la mainmise des grandes firmes
sur ces ogm ça aussi c'est en train de
basculer
rien n'interdit à des désirs des
organismes publics de donner le fruit de
leurs recherches
d'ailleurs les brevets commencent à
tomber sur certains maïs bt résistant à
la pyrale tiens par exemple un institut
public en colombie est l'un des premiers
à sortir alors est ce qu'il est pape
d'arrière-garde ce qu'on va bloquer les
ogm ans j'ai l'impression que vous
parlez aux qui pour monsanto qui pour
saint-jean taki pur plaisir qu'ils sont
en train de cartes elysées l'agriculture
du monde le problème que tu fais c'est
évoquer vous vous sortez quand même des
placards des vieux trucs le documentaire
de marie monique robin sur wii je les
regardais monsanto est allé voir en asie
par exemple ceci ce qui se passait
notamment en inde où des dizaines de
milliers des milliers de paysans se sont
suicidés parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
racheter
des semences ogm qu'elle seulement un
site des semences ogm c'est qu'elles
sont cette élection c'est non elle ne
suis pas stérile et ça c'est un jeu
c'est vous écouter on va pas faire un
discours t on va pas faire un nom mais
ces discours ne voulons pas parce que je
parce que c'est la réalité c'est que
l'on transforme les champs de nos
paysans en paillasse de laboratoire avec
comme je ne vous ne voulez pas qu'on
développe moi j'ai de gm par exemple
comme seul le ghana ensuite quand
argentine le ghana en ce moment est en
train de tester un ogm qui quitte moi je
suis documentaire qui sue à différentes
documentaire pour france 5 il ya
quelques années avec jean michel venne
manille au mali où les paysans se sont
battus contre monsanto et pioneer qui
voulait imposer un coton ogm il n'y a
pas de coton ogm il est beaucoup plus
rentable et les gens sont beaucoup moins
malade que vous avec nous au taureau gm
entonné les archers à la question des
grandes eaux je compte aussi parce que
kiki zanetti vis à vis des ogm
ce sont mon sens tokyo où les ogm
problème de la faim une série z rappaz
par le rideau rayonne il se résoudre à
part une autre agriculture par l'agro
écologie quand se vous savez je suis
écrivait sexy mais que la grille et
legault logis pour être pareil sort et
nourrir le mandat
à rebours de même les prochains jours de
toutes les preuves scientifiques vous
considérez dit hervé le braz comme un
vélo fait scientifique vous considérez
l'agroécologie pour peuvent énormément
grippe et oui c'est un cet homme c'est
des mots gravité un démographe et on a
des mandats alors fait référence à la
partie je crois qu'il y connaît
l'obsession l'agroécologie et marc
dufumier connais rien la gombe et colis
vous avez un message à ses fans
l'agroécologie la question est de savoir
si on peut si on peut assimiler et
supporter sur cette terre plus
d'habitants qu'il y en a aujourd'hui il
y a ceux qui dans la continuité des
religieux comme je le cite dans mon
livre qui en 1968 avec un livre qui
s'appelle la bombe p la bombe population
qui a d'ailleurs engendré des politiques
anti nataliste très très durs comme par
exemple la stérilisation des femmes au
pérou ou en inde
et on sait très bien que la fertilité on
peut l'affirmer sein par l'éducation des
femmes ça a été bien sûr en algérie y
est et dans bien d'autres endroits et
que par exemple on sait aujourd'hui
il faut 3 à 10 calories végétales pour
faire une calorie animale
donc on peut peut-être aussi éviter de
faire le saut j'ai transgénique qui
viennent nourrir ne s'applique un peu je
note que vous avez aimé d'aller à
rebours je suis j'aime on va pas vous
mettre d'accord c'est une évidence de la
pio note que dans ceux des scanneurs de
chantal du à l'interné vous l'avez lu
avec le regard moi et je le regrette
beaucoup cette saison mais elle avait
envie d'aller vous cherchez sur des ogm
et c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
parce qu'on danse y aller me chercher
sur d'autres choses moi j'ai juste envie
parce qu'on va quand même via pas du
tout que ce sujet là je ne regrettais
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai écrit sur les
ogm et je le maintiens et vous verrez
que c'est à lui reçoit un parcours au
fond vous avez vous vous rendez hommage
à ceux qui vous ont rendu écologistes à
vos maîtres d'une certaine manière
jacques ellul qu'on connaît d'autres
bernard charbonneau que personne durant
quelques grands penseurs de l'écologie
parce que je consomme le monde a repris
on a l'impression de découvrir
l'écologie mais c'est une idée
c'est une idée qui apparaît neuf sont en
vient de loin mais les penseurs qui
remonte henry david thoreau franjou noël
alors dans ce mini d'après très très
sincèrement ou vous arrange ou dans ce
monde d'après ou l'écologie devient
francs est évidemment dans le rang des
pessimistes ou dans le rang des hogra je
pense qu'il faut être pessimiste dans ce
pays mais le pessimisme est aussi ce qui
permet de se battre pour essayer de
transformer la société
donc être un optimisme béat c'est être
utopiste être un pessimiste positif en
tout cas un pessimiste qui croient qu'on
a plus de raisons d'espérer que de
désespérer même si on est pessimiste sur
la question et que la syrie natixis est
toujours c'est toujours l'opportunité
on rentre dans une crise économique qui
va devenir social qui peut même devenir
financière ça coûte cher l'écologie
c'est zorro coûte pas cher mais bon
c'est ça qui feront alors il faut que
j'essaie de paris jugé que l'esprit
vente est ce que ça coûte moins cher la
nommant est venu véritablement c'est est
ce qu'on peut faire
au fond la meilleure des révolution
écologique vert vers une lutte pour le
réchauffement climatique l'état contre
le réchauffement climatique maintenant
c'est maintenant qu'il faut maintenant
quand je
c'est maintenant lancée et se servir du
de cette épidémie due qu'aux vives 19
comme une sorte d' accélérateur de
particules pour mettre en place des
politiques publiques qui vont freiner le
dérèglement climatique parce que ce
qu'on doit dire à ceux qui nous
regardent c'est que l'on sortira sans
doute dû coronavirus peut être dans
longtemps avec toujours d'autres menaces
de pandémie
parce que la déforestation et parce que
la manne et l'agro-industrie fait que
l'on gagne sur le monde sauvage et que
ce monde sauvage ils portent des virus
qui ne sont pas pathogènes pour lui mais
qui le sont pour nous et plus on se
rapprochera de lui plus on sera menacée
par par cc pandémie mais il faut qu'on
essaie d'expliquer que lolo dérèglement
climatique
il est à l'oeuvre et qu'une fois le
corno virus passé il y aura toujours
ceux directement climatique c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs grave
je pense que ce sont les jeunes qui
aujourd'hui sont victimes de cette
double peine ils vont être victimes de
la peine qu'il consiste à ne pas trouver
d'emploi
en sortant du kovy 2010 10h09 comme lui
il ya une grande récession et ils vont
être les principaux acteurs qui devront
se battre contre ledit règlement cette
affaire nous devons nous dire qu'est ce
qu'on leur remet ça mais lequel serait
la grande réforme faire de toute urgence
jean jouzel par exemple on sait très
tendu jacques d'iquitos très respectable
absolument tout mettre sur
l'alimentation c'est à dire relocaliser
et produire en france dans
l'agroalimentaire toute l'agriculture
qu'on pourrait faire en france pas
forcément faire plaisir des bananes mais
c'est ça la priorité qu'il n'y a pas une
priorité
de toute façon quand on mène des
politiques publiques on doit faire des
choix qui ne sont pas qu'ils ne peuvent
pas s'axer sur un seul thème
donc il y a plusieurs priorités qui sont
par exemple et on l'a dit depuis
longtemps parce que pour 1 million
dépensé cc 15 emplois c'est par exemple
l'isolation des bâtiments qu'ils soient
des bâtiments publics aux des bâtiments
privés
c'est une autre politique des transports
vous allez je vous donne un exemple on
en a jamais parlé on vient de donner je
sais pas combien de milliards à
renault rno qui sur laquelle la pratique
est un véritable délinquant erreur de
dans les erreurs qui ont été faites dans
sort de sa politique industrielle
et maintenant d'ailleurs on peut
comparer renault à la question du
dérèglement climatique parce qu'on est
toujours dans le déni mille et une
compagnie qui s'appelle cma-cgm vous
avec le transport maritime
c'est 90% du transport mondial que de
transport c'est la troisième entreprise
au monde
aujourd'hui les chinois sont en train de
guigné cgc amassé gm et on pourrait très
bien considérer qu'il s'agit d'une
entreprise qui est une entreprise
stratégique notamment le transport
maritime puisqu'il est un des plus
importants et se fixer des objectifs
flécher les investissements sur par
exemple du transport du transport vert
avec les progrès de l'hydrogène vert
dans le transport maritime est ce que
vous voyez pour quelle curieuse mais
bien sur la question l'alimentation ça
veut dire qu'il faut que l'on arrête
d'aller il faut qu'on arrête les ogm
il faut qu'on arrête la déforestation
pour y planter des palmiers à huile qui
vont simplement contribué à nourrir
notre bétail manger moins de viande puis
à un autre il ya une autre question qui
est aussi celle de de ce qu'on appelle
le coeur c'est-à-dire le soin et je
pense que cette priorité elle est
aujourd'hui évidente depuis la question
du coville c'est à dire qu'il ya tout un
pan de la société qui aujourd'hui a été
négligée considéré comme subalterne et
qui doit devenir prioritaire si on veut
créer du lien social et vous laisse le
mot de la fin
les verts sont un aiguillon que ça fait
longtemps
oui est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous qui
regardez les politiques publiques à
l'heure vous diriez que ce sont les plus
écologistes véritablement parce qu'on
voit en matière de rénovation thermique
sur les transports ce que bon jeu
politique ce n'est pas le cas et ce qui
fait que même si l'essai est transformé
pour les municipales vous risquez
d'atteindre à échéance brève une espèce
de deux gaps parce que certaines des
solutions qui sont des icônes des
marqueurs
du parti europe ecologie les verts de
l'écologie politique vont à l'encontre
de ce qu'il faudrait faire pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
prenez la fermeture à la nuque les airs
quand on voit ce que ça donne en
allemagne est très bon je suis un verre
je suis au contraire les collègues je me
défoule va pas faire le débat quand même
le nucléaire vous voyez ça c'est alors
qu'il ya d'autres façons de faire de
l'écologie pour lui et tant qu'a dit
différentes ordonné mois d'août avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour vous mais
depuis le début de cette interview vous
êtes en train d'enfiler les lieux
communs comme non j'ai lu le rapport du
chèque qu'il n'a pas d'émissions de gaz
à effet terme à part faire ses preuves
de l'émission de gaz à effet de serre
che dans le dans le nucléaire est ce que
les accidents de tchernobyl et je sais
bien moi je sais bien ne laisse pas se
ranger ce que je vous propose le charbon
pas du tout c'est ce qui se produit pas
écouter les économies d'énergie et
l'efficacité a neigé énergétique ne
nécessite pas de de développer des
centrales à charbon
il ya effectivement il centrales à
charbon qui vient d'être construite en
allemagne et qui va ouvrir
contre l'avis de la population et des
écolos moussavi parquet a été
principalement financé par bnp paribas
et par la société générale alors que les
banques françaises qui n'arrête pas de
nous dire qu'elles sont vertueuses
arrête quand elle met un euro pour les
énergies renouvelables
elles investissent 7 euros dans les
énergies fossiles c'est par là qu'il
faut commencer l'écologie pour sauver
nos vies
c'est aux éditions les petits matins ça
raconte votre engagement vos m quelques
figures de la jeunesse aussi vous parler
de great attenberg et puis vous parlez
aussi de ces résistances encore à cette
conversion pour sauver la planète vous
restez avec nous à noël mamère merci
beaucoup géraldine j'aimerais qu'on dise
un mot sur cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire qui seyait va commencer
ses travaux il s'agit de savoir si oui
ou non le gouvernement a bien géré cette
crise du coc vide 19 toutes les
explications c'est thomas des prêts qui
va nous les donner oui exactement myriam
la commission d' enquête sur le corps en
un virus a été installé cet après midi
mais à quoi va-t-elle servir
je vous explique tout ça jingle
alors c'était un des temps forts
attendus de cette semaine à l'assemblée
cet après midi les députés qui
composaient la mission d'information sur
le corner virus se sont réunis en vrai
en présentiel comme on dit maintenant
pour dresser le bilan des auditions
qu'ils ont mené une mission
d'information a procédé à 17 audition
elle a suivi de très près la gestion de
la crise sanitaire en auditionnant les
principaux acteurs impliqués ainsi que
les mesures de mise à neuf de l'état
d'urgence et leur application dans les
territoires c'est ce rapport d'étape il
est au fond à l'image de ce qu'a été le
travail parlementaire et la vie
parlementaire pendant la période du
confinement travaille essentiellement
contemplatif
j'ai pas tout à fait le sentiment d'y
retrouver y compris l'esprit des
questions que j'ai pu y poser mais c'est
sans doute la règle du jeu
cette réunion s'était donc aussi
l'occasion d'installer cette commission
d' enquête qui va prendre le relais
pendant six mois pour faire toute la
lumière sur cette épidémie
elle s'intéressera notamment à la
prévention à la gestion de crise pendant
le confinement notamment sur la question
des masques aux réponses des systèmes de
soins ou encore aux déconfinement ce
sont les députés les républicains et
leur président damien abad qui ont
demandé que la mission d'information se
transforme en commission denquête dès
maintenant au même moment qu'au sénat je
pense qu'on a besoin à l'assemblée
nationale d'abord une véritable
commission denquête on ne peut pas
passer à côté de ce sujet qui est un
sujet central
on ne peut pas mettre la poussière sur
le tapis s'agit pas pour nous d'en faire
un tribunal populaire il s'agit
simplement d'en faire un lieu de vérité
de transparence et un lieu surtout on
tire un certain nombre de leçons pour
l'avenir pour que plus jamais ça il y
aura une trentaine de députés de tous
les groupes parlementaires en proportion
de leur nombre d'élus la présidente sera
brigitte bourguignon la députée la
république en marche il y aura quatre
vice président et le rapporteur général
l'un des postes les plus importants sera
occupé par un député les républicains
eric ciotti bonjour brigitte bourguignon
les républicains veulent que cette
commission denquête soit utile pas comme
celle de la sphère benalla distille son
républicains qui ont demandé cette
commission denquête comme d'autres
groupes l'on demandait ensuite bien sûr
que chacun d'entre nous de toute façon
veux que cette commission d' enquête
soit productive soit riche
d'enseignement parce que c'est quand
même le but on n'est ni des enquêteurs
ni pas changer de rôle nous sommes des
parlementaires avant tout qui voulons
comprendre
recherchez les dysfonctionnements voire
éventuellement on peut améliorer les
choses faire des propositions c'est à ça
que sert pour moi une mission d' enquête
de parlementaires on devrait connaître
la semaine prochaine le nom des premiers
responsables convoqué par cette
commission denquête une chose est sûre
ce ne sera ni edouard philippe
ni l'ancien ministre de la santé agnès
luisant qui seront convoquées plus tard
mais pas pendant la campagne des
élections municipales où ils sont tous
les deux candidats mais ça on aura
l'occasion de reparler dans ma journée à
l'assemblée
noël mamère on a beaucoup dit que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire avait suspendu
l'état de droit va y avoir une
commission denquête le parlement reprend
son rôle de contre-pouvoir vous fait
confiance à cette commission denquête je
fais confiance à la commission d'
enquête parlementaire mais je suis très
dubitatif sur son résultat en expérience
de 20 ans de parlement m'a montré que
les commissions d'enquêté parlementaires
pouvaient aboutir à l'exact contraire de
ce que l'on recherchait ce l'attendent
elle voit tient seule chose que je
retiens de cet état d'urgence celui lié
au terrorisme est celui lié à la
question sanitaire c'est que ce que l'on
nous propose comme temporaire risque de
passer dans le droit commun comme ça a
été le cas après l'état d'urgence et les
lois qui ont été votées sous cette
majorité annoncera l'arrivée en effet
nous sommes surveillés sont menacés dans
nos librairies fossé risque de se
réveiller avec la gueule de bois
merci beaucoup noël mamère merci
géraldine maintenair d'être venu vous
frotter à noël mamère sur ce plateau
vous restez on va passer à la chronique
d'alex taylor alex qui vous le savez est
un peu dé facto notre correspondant
parlement britannique
oui c'est passé à westminster cette
semaine quelque chose d'absolument
incroyable alex oui mais rien mais on
peut pas reprocher en effet au parlement
britannique d'être avare de seine
abracadabrante s'est amené dans hier
encore c'était ubuesque après deux mois
d'absence et surtout de débats et de
votes virtuel électronique les députés
sont revenus
cette semaine et comme vous voyez sur
ces images
ils ont respecté la tradition
britannique tokyu de faire la queue
surtout avec les normes de sécurité
fallait ainsi plié entre chaque député
s'était plus ou moins bataille de m en
temps normal ces 15 minutes pour se
rendre les lobbies pour voter et là
c'était 45 minutes pour un seul vote
d'innombrables tweet de députés exaspéré
contre l' attente interminable voilà la
démocratie au 21ème siècle tweet c'est
une députée travailliste par exemple et
vous allez me demander mais rien mais
pourquoi il faisait la queue en pestant
contre ce système si archaïque et
manifestement inadaptées ou temps
modernes
là on se le demande alors pourquoi et
pour maintenir justement ce système si
archaïque manifestement inadaptées aux
temps modernes
ils ont mis fin donc au vote
électronique
le souci myriam c'est qu'il ya 200
députés britanniques qui ont des raisons
médicales n'ont pu se déplacer il veut
pas se dépasser physiquement au
parlement et leurs collègues hier
présent sur ordre du gouvernement john
sinon ont voté pour qu'il n'ait pas le
droit de vote ça pour un véritable
problème démocratique car leurs
électeurs se trouve du coup privé de
représentation certaines mauvaises
langues diraient que c'est pour rendre
la période de législation sur le break
site plus facile pour le gouvernement
déjà largement majoritaires mais avec ce
système qui décourage la pause
d'amendements et de manière plus
générale débat sur ce break site qui
pour rappel était censé redonner du
pouvoir aux parlements et à la
démocratie britannique
merci beaucoup alex taylor on termine
comme tous les soirs avec le jour
d'après et ce nouvel épisode de notre
collection d'entretien ce soir à quoi
ressemblera le travail le monde du
travail le télétravail dans ce jour
d'après que nous commençons doucement à
découvrir la sociologue dominique méda
ce choc du travail vous accorde cet
entretien pourquoi c'est un petit peu
voilà ça va ça va bien et vous là bas
[Musique]
bonjour dominique méda bonjour on va
parler du travail votre thème de
recherche depuis de longues années
totalement bouleversé dans cette période
de crise sanitaire
depuis le début du confinement ce monde
de travail il est divisé en trois d'un
côté ceux qui doivent continuer à
travailler et qu'ils prennent des
risques au quotidien face au virus
d'un autre côté ceux qui travaillent de
chez eux
et puis ceux qui sont mis à l'arrêt ceux
qui sont au chômage
qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit cette vision
de la société du travail aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de reprendre vos trois
catégories sur la troisième catégorie
salir les gens qui ont complètement
arrêté de travailler ça va être très
intéressant de d'avoir un retour de sur
ce qu'il pense parce qu'à mon avis ils
vont avoir deux perceptions assez
différente d'une part peut-être une
certaine satisfaction on voit d'ailleurs
des témoignages de gens qui disent enfin
on casse avec ce rythme intense qui
était le nôtre auparavant donc enfin
retrouver les enfants un peu de loisirs
un peu de repos il ya tous ceux qui vont
comprendre comprendre un nouveau combien
de travail est important dans leur vie
et combien travail et structurant et
puis je prends les deux autres
catégories le télétravail c'est super on
peut continuer à échanger à à prolonger
nos activités mais il ya plein
d'inconvénients énormément
d'inconvénients le fait qu'on est tout
seul face à face à un écran
du coup le fait qu'on est détaché de son
collectif de travail et qu'on peut avoir
un employeur qui va charger à fond la
barque et puis surtout le fait qu'il ya
une sorte de vraiment de perméabilité de
brouillage des frontières entre le
travail et le haut et puis la dernière
catégorie alors alors la dernière
catégorie elle est absolument
déterminant c'est tous ceux qui sont au
front en première ligne un jeu file la
métaphore guerrière et donc évidemment
tous les soignants mais aussi les
caissières des livreurs les personnes
le nettoyage qui vont quand même souvent
au travail la peur au ventre parce que
ils n'ont pas ou ils n'ont pas eu
pendant longtemps les équipements de
protection nécessaire qu'ils n'osent pas
exercé leur droit de retrait parce que
souvent c'est des personnes qui ont déjà
de faibles revenus et qui ont peur de
perdre leur emploi et qui vivent quelque
sorte la double peine parce qu'on le
voit bien là ça y est on a des données
qui commencent à sortir les personnes
qui sont le plus contaminé est en
réanimation et peut-être qu'ils décèdent
du virus se sont déjà les personnes les
plus pauvres et qui en plus prennent
tous les risques pour aller au travail
souvent d'ailleurs ces caissières ces
routiers avaient enfilé un gilet jaune
réclamait de l'arbre la reconnaissance
du pouvoir d'achat et ce sont eux les
essences yen est plus utile et ce qu'on
applaudit tous les soirs à 20h
on va faire de cette reconnaissance la
promesse est très c'est très frappant
moi je moi je trouve que vraiment c'est
une des plus grandes leçons de la crise
c'est cette espèce de distorsion énorme
entre la hiérarchie du prestige de la
reconnaissance de la considération et
des salaires d'un côté et de l'utilité
sociale de l'autre parce que comme vous
le disiez à part les médecins les
techniciens les infirmières qui quand
même sont des professions prestigieuse a
énormément de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
au front sont des gens qui sont dans des
métiers parfois pas très bien considérée
souvent regroupés dans la catégorie
emplois non qualifiés
je passais vous rendez compte qu'il ya 5
millions d'emplois non qualifiés en
france qui sont sous payés il faut juste
qu'on se souvienne que par exemple une
aide soignante ou une caissière c'est un
un salaire net médian à temps complet
autour de 1300 à 1500 euros
l'autre élément très frappant un beau
coup de phare beaucoup de femmes en
première ligne et d'ailleurs ça n'est
pas sans lien s'il y a beaucoup de
femmes dans ces métiers peut payer c'est
parce que d'abord les femmes sont
souvent à temps partiel
on les oblige on les contraint à être à
temps partiel et aussi parce qu'on
considère qu elle s'arme toute éternité
faire tout ça hein soigner faire les
toilettes
un peu sourire elles savent très bien le
faire c'est naturel donc ça n'a pas
besoin d'être pillés est-ce que c'est
ces infirmières donc des fonctionnaires
est ce que ces enseignants est ce que
ces caissières ces livreurs ces routiers
vont être augmentés est ce qu est ce que
c est une forme d'obligation presque
morale aujourd'hui je pense que si vous
interrogez les français aujourd'hui le
dirai oui que c'est absolument
nécessaire
je pense qu'ils iraient plus loin et
qu'il dirait qu'il faut aussi revoir la
hiérarchie des salaires et essayer de
travailler c'est cette distorsion donc
j'ai parlé entre guérard chi du prestige
et des salaires d'un côté de l'utilité
sociale ajoutant ce que les français il
vous répondrait mais oui il faut
resserrer cette échelle de salaires
évidemment et il faut plus payer les
gens qui exercent des métiers essentiels
qui nous ont permis de survivre dans
cette situation mais est-ce qu'on va
réussir
est-ce qu'on va réussir à faire ça alors
qu'on va nous dire que 1 les caisses de
l'état sont vides attendait regardez
déjà on a perdu d'état pointe pipe et
puis les employeurs pareil ils vont nous
dire mais nous sommes déjà prêts à
mettre la clé sous la porte nous ne
pouvons pas je pense que ça va pas être
facile mais qu'il faudra exercer
vraiment qu'il faudra se mobiliser pour
porter cela et qu'on a des solutions
moins on peut revaloriser toutes les
personnes à à bas salaires et on peut
elle alors précisément prenons l'exemple
de l'entreprise
là on est dans sa sphère privée on fait
quoi on augmente les salaires on oblige
les entreprises à le faire où on
augmente le smic alors on peut augmenter
le smic
même si les comités d'experts nous
disent depuis des années que augmenter
le smic c'est très mauvais pour pour
l'emploi et puis il ya aussi vous savez
des négociations obligatoires sur le sur
les sur les salaires on peut revoir ça
c'est des chercheuses qui propose ça
c'est très intéressant
revoir la grille de classification parce
que ce sont là des grilles sur
lesquelles on se fonde pour arrêter les
salaires et donc notamment sur la
question des salaires féminins avec des
classifications je vous disais que les
compétences naturelles ne sont pas
reconnus là on peut vraiment travailler
et puis de l'autre côté avec quoi on
pourrait payer tout ça ben avec la
limitation des rémunérations
exorbitantes sait très bien que les
inégalités dans notre pays sont vraiment
insupportable elles le seront d'autant
plus aujourd'hui et dont on peut mettre
de nouvelles tranches de l'impôt sur le
revenu et revenir à l'impôt sur la
fortune je pense que ça aidera à
resserrer les gens taille des revenus et
des patrimoines pour terminer enfin sur
ces indispensables
les caissières par exemple dans certains
supermarchés en france aux états unis
elles sont remplacées par des robots
c'est ces caissières ne seront plus
robotisée bhl dans le monde d'après à
votre avis si vous voulez je j'ai envie
de vous dire que on a vécu depuis
quelques années avec cette idée que le
paradigme du futur c'est l
automatisation que 50 % des emplois
allait disparaître
moi je crois le contraire parce que
l'automatisation elle est coûteuse en
gaza et fait en gaz à effet de serre
pour moi la crise convient c'est un coup
de semonce qui nous prévient que la
prochaine crise climatique sera encore
plus différente encore plus terrifiant
et donc je pense qu'il faut que la con
entre vraiment dans une forme de
reconversion écologique ou c'est pas du
tout l'automatisation qui va être
essentiel mais aussi été justement ses
métiers ses métiers qui nous permettent
de satisfaire les besoins sociaux qui
vont devenir complètement déterminé
alors à côté c'est indispensable par
contraste est ce qu'il ya certains
emplois qui se sont un peu révélés
inutiles
ou alors certaines personnes qui dans le
confinement se sont dit mais à quoi je
sers personne ne m'appelle je n'ai pas
le sentiment d'exister socialement dans
mon entreprise dans ce temps si grave
est-ce que ça va susciter des des
reconversions est ce que certains
emplois pourraient disparaître
c'est très difficile pour quelqu'un de
se dire mon métier qu'inutile 1 c'est le
sociologue david grébert qui nous parle
des bullshit job et d'ailleurs on voit
bien il y avec des enquêtes ont demandé
aux gens est ce que vous vous avez un
bol si jobs alors il commence à dire oui
peut-être que c'est trop dur trop
difficile de dire mon boulot c'est un
bourreau qui sert à rien en revanche je
pense que les jeunes vont se poser
énormément de questions et que la
société dans son ensemble doit se poser
la question de la différence je dirais
entre création de valeur pour la société
et création de valeur pour l'actionnaire
parlons du télétravail est ce que vous
savez d'ailleurs combien il ya eu de
télétravailleurs dans le pays est ce qu
on a les chiffres qu'on parle de 40% des
actifs qui auraient travaillé à distance
alors moi j'ai aussi se chiffre ainsi un
chiffre dont on a beaucoup parlé au
début quand on a pris les mesures
j'en ai pas vu d'autres depuis donc on
va rester sur ce chiffre là oui beaucoup
de gens les travail et donc c'est à la
fois très intéressante elle et travaille
avec des progrès fabuleux infirme nous
nous faisons nous les professeurs nous
faisons court grâce à des logiciels
c'est vrai que c'est formidable parce
que on peut continuer l'activité en même
temps c'est très inconfortable et pour
nous et pour les étudiants et donc je
suppose pour tous les gens qui font des
réunions en télétravail a priori d'après
les premiers sondages les français
regrettent un peu de bureaux
majoritairement haut oui je pense
alors c'est toute l'ambivalence du
télétravail je pense que un ou deux
jours par semaine
c'est très intéressant ça permet un peu
de décompresser ça nous fait faire des
économies de déplacement et donc c'est
très bon pour la pollution
ça permet de se rendre en un peu de
services pour la conciliation vie
familiale et professionnelle on entend
que vous souhaiter qu'au fond notre
rapport au travail change en quelques
mots
vers quel horizon alors je vous dis mon
idéal mon idéal ça serait que nous ayons
suffisamment investi dans la
reconversion écologique de nos sociétés
rapatrié de nombreuses productions créer
de nombreux emplois et qu'on en profite
pour développer de nouvelles
organisations du travail sans doute plus
fondées sur des métiers utiles plus
démocratique et somme toute peut-être
finalement plus efficace
merci beaucoup c'est moi qui vous
remercie voilà ainsi s'achève cette
émission merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis très belle soirée sur lcp à
demain
[Musique]